[Music]
welcome back to harvard unbox today
we're taking our first
look at the new 1 000 radeon rx
6900xt amd's most expensive radeon
product
to ever feature just a single gpu but
before we do check out the 6900 xt
my sidekick tim has today's video
sponsor
experience ultimate performance and get
pixel perfect detail with the new msi
optics mag
274 qrf-qd monitor race hell in game and
soak in a blazing fast 165 hertz refresh
rate
stunningly quick rapid ips panel with
unrivaled color reproduction that topped
our own gaming monitor charts here at
hardware unboxed
all backed with nvidia g-sync
compatibility right out of the box
offering 1440p resolution at 27 inches
in size
msi really has set a new standard for
enthusiast gaming monitors
if a gaming monitor could be described
as coming close to perfect this would be
it
so learn more about msi's new optics
mag274 qrf-qd monitor
via the links below okay thanks tim once
everyone's finished checking those uh
those links down below we'll we'll get
back to the
xt okay well that should be about enough
time
so we'll get back to this thing and what
was i talking about again
yeah that's right dual gpus so in years
gone
we've seen one thousand dollar plus
radio and gpus but they've always been
dual gpu designs such as the 1 000 radio
hd 7990
or the insane 1500 us radeon r9
295 x2 for example both of which
they kind of sucked as they relied
heavily on driver and game support for
crossfire
the 6900xt doesn't suffer from those
issues packing a single gpu with 5120
cores
however that doesn't mean it's any
better in terms of value
when compared to the 6800 xt we're
getting just 11 percent more cores and
tmus with the same 128 rops and the
cores
are clocked at the same 2 250 megahertz
because the memory subsystem goes
unchanged we're looking at 16 gigabytes
of gddr6
16 gigabits per second memory on a 256
bit wide bus
for a peak bandwidth of 512 gigabytes
per second
all in all the 6200 xt is set to be no
more than 11
faster than the 6800 xt while costing
over 50 percent more
at least according to amd's msrp
that's kind of really all you need to
know about the 6900xt
but of course we'll go over some
benchmark data because
that's kind of what we do but like the
geforce rtx 3090 review
i'm gonna cut this one a bit short so
we'll look at a few games and then jump
into the 18 game average
followed by the cost per frame and all
that other good stuff
actually speaking of the rtx 3090 the
6900 xt
wouldn't exist without it i'm sure
you've noticed over the years how
mainstream video gaming's become
if you're under the age of 30 and you
don't play video games you probably now
considered to be a bit of an outlier
that being the case as gaming's grown in
popularity the demand for pc hardware
has increased
and while some people would assume that
the increased demand means mass
production and therefore
lower prices that's not always the case
with limited competition and an
increased difficulty to achieve
performance gains
pricing of graphics cards has only
continued to increase
products like the rtx 3080 and 6800 xt
are likely
quite reasonably priced but why limit
yourself to reasonably priced graphics
cards when there's a market for exotic
over-the-top products
like the 1500 us rtx 3090
nvidia has been testing the waters with
flagship gpus priced well over one
thousand dollars us for years now
and has discovered that there are those
willing to spend big dollars
just to have the best even if it is the
best buy
only a very small margin in the case of
the rtx 3090 they decided to offer a
gaming graphics card that's less
than 20 fast and their next best
offering
while charging well over twice as much
amd's of course followed suit and
created the 6900 xt
allowing them to cash in on gamers with
well how should i put it
more money than cents amd's premium may
be less when compared to nvidia's but
you're also getting
less performance with no real added
perks
for example at least the 39e is offering
well over twice the vram capacity at 24
gigabytes
versus 10 gigabytes for the 3080. the
1600xt as i mentioned a moment ago shows
the same
16 gigabyte configuration as the 6800 xt
so in my opinion it's even less special
it also means that the 6900xt packs 33
less vram than the rtx 3090 so the fact
that it's
33 cheaper might not convince gamers
with deep pockets to give
amd a go but i guess with availability
the way it is
most will just go with whatever they can
get their hands on
anyway we'll talk about that a bit later
in the video for now let's go over the
test system
and then get into some results the test
system uses the ryzen 93950x with 32
gigabytes of ddr4 3200 cl 14 memory
in a dual rank dual channel
configuration on the msi x570 unified
motherboard
okay let's get into the results
starting with death stranding at 1440p
we find that the 1600xt is just four
percent faster than the 6800 xt
and 3090 we're likely running into a cpu
limitation here with the average frame
rate up over 160 fps
moving to 4k does indicate that we were
seeing a cpu limitation at 1440p with
these higher end gpus
as the 6900xt is now 14 faster than the
6800xt
which is a bit beyond what i was
expecting to see it also meant that the
1600xt was able to edge ahead of the rtx
3090 beating it by a mere three percent
moving on to the rainbow six siege
results we see that 1440p the 6900 xt is
seven percent faster than the 6800 xt
and honestly that's what i'm typically
expecting to see the margin does open up
to 10 at 4k
and that puts the 1600 xt ahead of the
rtx 3080
but still eight percent behind the 3090.
next up we have watchdogs legion and at
1440p the 1600xt was 11
faster than the xt jumping up from 85
fps
to 94 fps and that nudged it ahead of
the rtx 3090
then at 4k we're looking at a 12
performance increase for the 1600 xt
over the 6800 xt
but that matter was still 10 slower than
the 30 90.
the 6900 xt looks pretty mighty in
assassin's creed valhalla it has to be
set at 1440p
offering a 12 performance increase from
the 6800 xt
making it 28 faster than the rtx 3090
keep in mind this is an amd sponsored
title but still that is very impressive
performance
now 4k the 3090 does come back quite
heavily though the 1600 xt was still
able to beat it by an 8
margin with 64fps on average that meant
it was 12
faster than the 6800 xt
do maternal saw the 6100 xt delivering a
performance boost from the 6800 xt at
1440p
though that meant it was still four
percent slower than the 1390
the margin to the 390 4k is here the
1600 xt was nine percent slower
though it was also now nine percent
faster than the 6800 xt
the last game i'm going to bother
looking at is godfall here the 1600 xt
was six percent faster than the 6800 xt
at 1440p and just two percent faster
than the 3090.
then finally at 4k the 6900 xt was just
faster than the 6800 xt which meant it
trailed the rtx 3090 by a seven percent
margin
so no real surprises there the 6100 xt
was up to 12 percent faster than the
6800 xt
and although it only has 11 more cores i
suspect that our sample was maintaining
a higher clock speed
in those titles when compared to the 600
x team we did see that in shut off the
tomb raider
still 12 is
pretty uninspiring given that this thing
costs over 50
more anyways let's take a look at the 18
game average data at 1080p
1440p and 4k before moving into the
power temps overclocking and cost per
frame graphs
oh and we'll also take a detailed look
at ray tracer performance
for those of you targeting low
resolution high refresh rate gaming the
6900 xt
is a better choice than the 3090 though
it's typically
not that much better it's also not much
better than the 6800xt here we're
talking about a five percent boost on
average
and the 1440p games are ever so slightly
better
here the 6900 xt was an average eight
percent faster than the 6800 xt and just
two percent faster than the 3090
then at 4k the 1600 xt was on average
just 10
faster than the 6800 xt but also six
percent slower than the rtx 3090
given the performance you're getting
from the rtx 3080 and 6800 xt it's quite
clear that neither
the 6900xt or rtx 3090 make an ounce of
sense
here's a look at ray tracing performance
in control at 1440p using the medium and
high quality settings i've also tested
the 3090 with and without dlss enabled
basically we're looking at a 43
reduction performance for the 1600 xt
with medium quality ray tracing enabled
while the 3090 sees just a 23 reduction
and is still very playable
moreover if we enable dlss we see no
decrease in performance using the higher
quality ray tracing
obviously this game was developed and
optimized to take advantage of nvidia's
hardware
so it should come as little surprise
that it works much better with geforce
gpus
and this is likely something we're going
to see with all rtx optimized titles
another example of this would be
fortnite which is basically broken with
ray tracing enabled on the 6900 xt
at least in terms of performance that
said the performance hit is pretty
disgusting on the rtx 3090 as well
and even dlss struggles to get us
anywhere near native performance
this title can look very visually
impressive with ray tracing enabled but
it's not really a game that you'd
necessarily play with this feature
turned on
i for example use competitive quality
settings which sees things like shadows
disabled
so i don't really think fortnite is a
good fit for ray tracing
light control metro exodus was optimized
for turing so naturally it plays well
with
ampere and not so well with our dna 2's
ray tracing support
here we're looking at a 66 reduction in
performance when using the ultra quality
ray tracing with the 1600 xt
but just a 31 reduction with the 30 90.
in my opinion ray tracing in shot of the
tomb raider is a complete bust and i
really struggle to tell the difference
when it's enabled
so the 71 hit to the frame rate when
using ultra array traced shadows on the
1600 xt
is completely unacceptable and really so
is the 36 percent hit we see with the 30
finally we have watchdogs legion which
is one of two games that actually use
raytraced effects well
the other being control the 6100 xt
faces a 56
performance reduction with ultra array
tracing enabled whereas the rtx 390 saw
a 35
reduction though just 12 percent with
dlss enabled
now here's a look at total system power
consumption and quite surprisingly the
6900 xt
only uses slightly more power than the
xt presumably we are looking at better
quality silicon here
and when using nvidia's pcat we again
see that the 6900 xt only uses
slightly more power than the 6800 xt
here we're talking about a one percent
increase in power usage
so again this will be down to the 600 xt
using higher quality silicon
then when compared to the rtx 3090 the
6900 xt consumed to 14
less power though it was also slower in
doom
so when looking at performance per watt
we see that the 1600xt is only slightly
better than the rtx 3090
five percent better in this example our
amd 1600 xt reference card ran five
degrees hotter than the 6800 xt model
despite using only a few watts more
power however
there is a big difference in fan speed
whereas the 6800 xt card spun its fans
at 1500 rpm
the 6900xt ran its fans at just 1100 rpm
which makes the 80 degree peak
temperature quite impressive
we also saw after 30 minutes of gameplay
and show of the tomb raider an average
clock frequency of 2
260 megahertz which is around 50
megahertz higher than what we saw in
this game with the 6800 xt
now like my amd reference 6800 xt
graphics card this
6900xt model isn't a great overclocker
i was able to push the calls up to 2.7
gigahertz in what man
and this saw a typical clock frequency
in games of around
2000 megahertz and while that's a 13
increase it only boosts the performance
in assassin's creed valhalla by five
percent three percent shut off the tomb
raider and
five percent in watchdogs legion i don't
know why the gains are so weak
but this is similar overclocking
behavior to what we saw with the
reference spec 6800 xt so
i'm keen to test out an aib1600xt as i
expect they will overclock much better
here we're seeing that the 6900xt comes
in at 47
more costly per frame when compared to
the 6800 xt
so that's kind of terrible basically it
represents the same kind of value as
something like the rtx 2080 super
that said it does look pretty great in
terms of value when compared to the rtx
so yeah i guess that's just how bad the
rtx 3090 is
things don't improve too much for the
6900 xt at 1440p here it's 43
more costly per frame when compared to
the 6800 xt despite being 35
better value per frame when compared to
the rtx 3090
then at 4k the 1600 xt is 40 more costly
per frame when compared to the 6800 xt
though it's almost 30 percent better
value per frame than the rtx 3090
still with the rtx 3080 and 6800 xt
offering a similar level of value as one
another
it's fair to say the 6900 xt is terrible
and the rtx 3090 is horrendous
i'm not really sure what more there is
to say at this point if you've watched
this video
up to this point you really know all
that you need to though if you just
watched the introduction you probably
learned all you needed to know there
basically the radeon rx 6900 xt was
never going to make sense
much like what we saw with the rtx 3090
though at least in that example we were
getting a lot more vram than the part
below it the 6900xt on the other hand
it's a 6800 xt with a few extra cores
enabled for
about a five to ten percent performance
boost so for the 6900 xt to make sense
it really can't be priced much above
maybe 750 u.s assuming that you could
buy a 6800 xt for 650
us which you can't really do right now
but we're hoping that that will be
something you'll be able to do early
next year at least that's what we're
pushing amd for anyway
kind of out of our hands not much we can
do about it but we can only try
speaking of which in a world where
availability isn't an issue
so bear with me on this one there is
literally
zero reason to buy a 6900 xt
you just wouldn't do it and the same is
also true for the rtx 3090 over the rtx
3080 unless for some reason
you require that extra vram but short of
that you just never buy the 1500
ampere gpu so the 6900 xt
is the very definition of a pointless
product it literally exists for no other
reason than to allow amd
and their partners to take advantage of
fanboys and
rich people with more money than sense
that being the case i can't recommended
the 1600 xt
just as i couldn't recommend the rtx 30
90.
having said all of that let's for a
moment pretend that both products
are reasonably priced which one should
you buy
if you're gaming at 4k or care about ray
tracing performance and i think the rtx
3090 is the better product
it is really too early to call the ray
tracing battle but
if you're interested in the games that
we have available today then the geforce
gpu is clearly the way to go
for those of you gaming at 1440p or
lower then the 6900xt is typically the
punchier card
though for the most part it is too close
to call so if they were available at the
same price
and it was a reasonable price then i do
feel the rtx 3090 would be the superior
product
however getting back to reality at
fifteen hundred dollars for thirty
ninety and one thousand dollars for the
1600 xt
the radeon gpu is clearly the better
value option
assuming you're heavily focused on ray
tracing and i think that might be an
issue for amd with these extreme
high-end gpus typically those with super
deep pockets who don't care that they're
spending fifty percent more for
ten percent or less performance they
probably won't care if it costs a
thousand dollars
or fifteen hundred dollars they'll just
go with the outright best product
because that's clearly what they're
after
and as i've said i think that product is
the rtx 3090
it offers 50 more vram more mature ray
tracing support that's currently
yielding
far better results in today's games dlss
2.0 support
and for the most part superior 4k gaming
performance
so as i see it the 6900 xt is kind of
stuck in this strange position where
it's really bad value compared to the
6800 xt
but kind of good value compared to the
rtx 3090
but people looking to invest in this
class of gpu obviously don't care about
value
they just want the best of the best and
in my opinion that isn't
the 6900xt so who then is going to buy
the 6900xt
again it's going to be diehard amd fans
and people who desperately want
a 6800 xt but can't find one and aren't
willing to wait
anyway that is going to do it for my
6900 xt review
in short don't buy it as doing so will
ensure that the next generation
is even more expensive but hell i said
that about the rtx 3090
and they've been selling like hot cakes
so i guess budget gaming is
kind of doomed and on that bombshell i'm
going to end this video
if you liked this rather depressing look
at the 6900 xt
make sure you smash that like button
because remember every dislike is a 6900
xt
sold by an ebay scalper true story
also you can join us over on patreon or
floatplane if you'd like to become a
harem box community member
you get access to our monthly live
streams tim and i will be doing one of
those
later this month we have an exclusive
discord chat for harbour and box
community members
very cool place tim and myself are
active over there a lot of very cool
people so if you've got questions or you
just want to talk about tech
really great place to do it also have q
and a's
sorry about that behind the scenes
content if you're interested links for
that stuff is in the video description
if not that is perfectly fine and i
would like to just thank you for
watching this video
i'm your host steve and i'll see you
again next time
[Music]
you